welcome back new york governor andrew
cuomo appearing to take a victory lap as
he promotes the launch of his new book
uh quote leadership lessons from the
covet 19
pandemic can you see why a lot of people
think if you say we're in the halftime
of this
that writing a book a retrospective in
the middle of it sort of celebrating the
things that you did right
feels off and strange no willie it's not
a celebration at all the game isn't over
well here's the thing parts of new york
city just re-entered lockdowns
and just yesterday the governor even
said a second statewide lockdown is
possible
so are those lessons premature a lot of
people think they are
joining me with the thoughts new york
city councilman joe borelli joe it's
good to see you this morning
good morning good morning i'm sorry it's
under such pathetic
pathetic circumstances well you know
let's take a look at some of these
numbers here
new york state coronavirus deaths 33 301
total state deaths and you can see
more than 6 600 nursing home deaths
you know a lot of people do take issue
with a book like this
do you well well they certainly should i
mean you know
given those numbers we saw more deaths
than the entire country of france i mean
an entire
large largely populated european country
new york state still had more deaths
and the part that's so insulting is that
as people were still
dying as people were still getting sick
as the uncertainty continued
and businesses were closing this was a
guy who used that moment
not only to take you know
contemporaneous notes for a future book
but he was actually glad handing
publishers shopping for agents
writing this book and doing the work
this is in the thick of this pandemic
when we lost more people again more than
any other state easily
but more than places like france and
spain it's upsetting it's troubling
i don't think there needs to be a
boycott necessarily because given his
last book sales of only about 3 000
copies
it doesn't seem like people are really
interested in him as an author to begin
with
um but people should really understand
how insulting it is for families to see
this man
profiting off of this book well yeah one
of those families is our own
meteorologist janice dean you know joe
better than anyone she's been fighting
this battle day in and day out both of
her in-laws
died um in assisted living care
facilities
and or nursing home one of each um you
know so she's one of many people who
still want questions on this and in fact
he was on yesterday on the today show
with willie geist and he asked a
question and take a listen to how this
exchange went down
what have you learned as you write about
in the book about the early stages that
you can apply to later for example
was it a mistake to send those coveted
positive patients back into nursing
homes
yeah here's the first lesson for this
nation willie
how did you not know the virus was
coming to the united states
i mean joe that is not an answer to that
question
and this is why he's dodging for so long
that he has
people like the incredible janice dean
who's up in albany every weekend on her
time off meeting with legislators
hosting rallies and raising awareness
about governor cuomo
think about it we're talking about what
every governor could have done
better per you know say to prevent loss
of life but really governor cuomo is one
of the only
large state governors where we're
actually able to point to
something that he did that actually
caused the loss of life in this pandemic
that that's almost unprecedented around
the world and again it's this march
25th order that placed people with covid
in nursing homes putting people in the
in the most vulnerable populations uh
that one could imagine
and this is something that he did it
it's it's this this book is as relevant
as like napoleon writing
how to invade russia and i'm i'm just
sorry but it's so upsetting
for so many people to see this man
trying to profit
and to see him have this victory tour
where he gets these softball questions
on all the morning news shows
yeah i mean a lot of people say he would
be better served to say look mistakes
were made here's what we've learned
here's what we're going to do going
forward but you know you're not really
hearing that so
joe borelli thank you for joining us
appreciate your time as always talk soon
thank you